[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de la respuesta de la
unión europea ante la invasión de
ucrania las sanciones contra rusia han
sido las adecuadas y cuáles son las
consecuencias para el kremlin y para la
unión europea debatimos el papel que ha
jugado la unión europea en estos días
que han cambiado por completo el mundo y
el continente con los eurodiputados manu
pineda del grupo de la izquierda europea
bienvenido manu
y con antonio lópez istúriz del partido
popular europeo bienvenida antonio
gracias me gustaría empezar con una
pregunta para los dos el jefe de la
diplomacia europea y josep borrell
asegura que con la invasión de ucrania
la unión europea ha roto muchos tabús ha
aplicado sanciones económicas sin
precedentes ha aprobado el envío de
armas ha activado la directiva que
permite dar protección a todos los
ucranianos que llegan a la unión europea
estamos viendo el desespero de una
europa que ahora si se hace valer
antonio si yo miraría en torno a la
imagen de esa solidaridad de la sociedad
europea de ciudadanos españoles a miles
de kilómetros de ucrania que están
taxistas transportistas ciudadanos
particulares que están yendo a llevar
ayuda humanitaria y trayendo refugiados
a españa yo creo que eso resume
perfectamente la unidad y la
coordinación que estamos teniendo en
europa respecto a este asunto podemos
hablar de seguridad de defensa lo que
quieran pero ahora mismo lo que está
sufriendo sobre el terreno lo que
podemos hacer los europeos es aliviar
indudablemente el sufrimiento del pueblo
ucraniano por todos los medios posibles
bueno bueno yo distinguiría entre la
respuesta que están dando los ciudadanos
que como dice el colega ejemplar la
solidaridad la humanidad florece en los
momentos más difíciles pero una cosa es
lo que está la respuesta de la
ciudadanía otra cosa de la de las
instituciones yo creo que la unión
europea está remando en el sentido
contrario al que debería
la salida a una guerra no es armar a uno
de los bandos la salida de una guerra no
imponer sanciones que al final está
repercutiendo contra nuestra propia
población no podemos decir más madera a
la guerra tenemos que decir alto el
fuego vamos a sentarnos vamos a negociar
cómo buscar una salida diplomática de
esto pero si rusia se niega a sentarse a
negociar cuál es la solución
bueno
nos encontramos no tenemos mucho tiempo
pero encontramos con que rusia lleva dos
años pidiendo un negociar y la unión
europea que tiene un papel muy
subordinado a los dictados de eeuu lo
que ha hecho es imponer sanciones y
facilitar facilitar la desestabilización
y putin se ha visto se ha visto con la
excusa perfecta para hacer algo que
parece que no le desagrada que entra en
una guerra en la que fomenta la política
de bloques la guerra fría pero
digamos que cuando abrió posibilidades
de negociar la unión europea lo que ha
hecho imponer sanciones ahora mismo
desgraciadamente parece parece que el
escenario es bastante peor que acceder
cuando teníamos la posibilidad de haber
evitado esto yo a mi juicio considero
que las medidas adoptadas están desde
luego lejos de la actitud que ha tenido
el señor putin puede haber tenido ocho
años de negociaciones invadió invadió
partes de crimea hace ya hace ocho años
ya fue a raíz de una invasión de una
ocupación de un territorio de un país
soberano y ahora volvemos a las andadas
cuando no les salen bien las
negociaciones invade y ataca y masacrar
a la población estábamos hablando de las
sanciones se han aprobado varios
paquetes ya vamos por cuarto se están
negociando un quinto una de las medidas
más efectivas según la unión europea ha
sido la cola de congelar la mitad de los
activos del banco central ruso o excluir
a una parte de los bancos rusos del
sistema swift mano has comentado que las
sanciones no son las adecuadas pero hay
algunas que si que sea adecuada aquí qué
opinas nosotros que estamos en contra de
la política de sanciones nosotros
creemos que la única solución es
legítima que imponga el consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas el eso es
que estas sanciones no la está pagando
putin o los oligarcas la está pagando mi
vecino que tiene que pagar a más de dos
euros el litro de gasoil
esos son los efectos reales y la
solución que da la unión europea del
señor borre es que pongamos menos
calefacción nosotros nosotros no podemos
hay cuestiones que son que son
incuestionables que son tangibles las
sanciones nos están afectando a los
oligarcas putin están nadando en ella
feliz
están afectando al pueblo ruso por
supuesto pero también a los pueblos de
la unión europea que vamos a ver como la
inflación se dispara como nos van a
faltar
determinados bienes básicos alimentos
carburantes gas
creemos y pensamos sinceramente que
la realidad nos da la razón que esas
sanciones no sólo no van a solucionar
este problema sino que están recayendo
sobre las capas más vulnerables de
nuestro pueblo
justamente para no hacer referencia a
las consecuencias
que en esto para la población hay alguna
que el tipo de equilibrio indudablemente
la unión europea no puede quedarse
callada y sin hacer nada ante la
agresión ante la invasión y ante el
ataque quien es el plato principal de
esta historia somos nosotros los
europeos que nadie se llame a engaño
ucrania tal vez sea el primero que
nosotros el plato principal porque
porque estamos somos una democracia y
eso es señor putin a sus oligarcas pues
no les gusta y ahí es donde van las
sanciones al señor putin y a los que le
mantienen
indudablemente tiene unos efectos
secundarios por supuesto que afecta
capas de la población indudablemente
pero yo creo que siempre las sanciones
europeas a diferencia de otros países y
por ahí nuestra de nosotros no tenemos
ninguna dependencia de eeuu porque
tenemos criterios bastante distintos en
materia de sanciones siempre en la
historia de sanciones europeas van
dirigidas a los dirigentes que han sido
los que han producido esta guerra que
todos compartiremos que queremos que se
acabe indudablemente pero claro oiga
quien la empezó pues tiene que pagar su
precio no vamos yo disculpa yo por
supuesto discrepo dependencia de eeuu
eeuu apunta y la unión europea- dispara
y estamos hablando ahora en el caso de
rusia pero podemos hablar en el caso de
china de venezuela y de cualquier país
nosotros desgraciadamente en vez de
tener una política exterior propia que
juega un papel de tender puentes entre
bloques lo que no hemos posicionado como
tropas de uno de los bloques y eso desde
luego no es bueno no bueno ni para ni
para la posición que tenía que jugar la
unión europea en este tablero ni para
los pueblos de la unión europea
es lo que estamos aquí no es decir yo
creo que no yo creo que hay una
diferencia entre eeuu hay cosas que me
gustan y no de eeuu por ejemplo su
estado bienestar no tiene no tiene como
tenemos nosotros en europa por ejemplo
pero hay muchas cosas que nos
diferencian pero una principal es que
somos democracias y eso no gusta y por
eso están constantemente atacándonos por
ahí porque no les gustamos porque somos
demócratas tenemos otra manera de ver
las cosas y en el caso de eeuu puede
salir elegido obama o donald trump le
guste usted o uno o el otro no pero sí
democracia en cambio en rusia el que se
opone al dictador de turno o es
envenenado o es impresionado nuestro
amigo álex alexéi navalni periodista
como usted en prisión ahora le acaban de
confirmar nueve años en prisión de
máxima seguridad y una multa no sé
cuántos millones de rublos ustedes cree
que eso es normal eso es una democracia
no es la democracia
nosotros tenemos pocos motivos para dar
lecciones de democracia en ucrania está
prohibido el partido comunista de
ucrania desde hace dos años pero es que
antes de ayer han suspendido a 11
partidos más uno de ellos el principal
partido de la posición con 42 diputados
yo creo que alardea de democracia si no
me quedaría ejercicio en verano menos
menos suspendida para que la posición es
que es mío el comparativo por europeo
han suspendido a 11 partido entre ellos
que te el principal partido de oposición
con 42 pues su principal partido es mío
es que a mí nadie me ha dicho que se
haya suspendido
diciendo 11 11 partido suspendido
digamos como europea poca clase de
democracia un periodista español pablo
gonzález detenido en un país miembro de
la unión europa
expuesto a 10 años de cárcel
porque es
bueno por lo que venía de ucrania que ha
dado una información distinta a la que
polonia quería que diera y por lo tanto
pues se considera propagandistas y le
imponen de años de cárcel que se habrá
quedado nosotros con más unión europea
donde tenemos a raperos encerrado en las
cárceles donde se mete en cárceles a
gente por poner una una pocas clases
democracia podemos dar por supuesto el
señor putin ninguna el señor putin mete
en la cárcel a los representantes
diputados del principal partido de
oposición que el partido comunista de la
federación rusa nuestro referente en
rusia ninguna clase pero nosotros
tampoco
veremos como cómo puede evolucionar toda
esta cuestión pero
sin duda la unión europea está dado
cuenta de esta dependencia que tiene
rusia a nivel económico también a nivel
energético es posible congelar las
relaciones con rusia o tarde o temprano
a pesar de esta guerra hay que estar
condenados a entenderse yo creo que fue
una mala práctica mala praxis de
gobiernos anteriores en la unión europea
de crear al final esta dependencia del
gas ruso lo puedo decir porque yo
llevaba años denunciando lo no podíamos
estar sólo dependiendo de nord stream 2
de la gran ruso es decir un país de un
dirigido dictador de una gran
inestabilidad política en fin por si es
que existe algo de política en ese país
no podíamos estar dependiendo teníamos
que diversificar las fuentes y sobre
todo lo que introdujo la presidenta de
la comisión úrsula von der layen el
greendale empezará a cambiar a energías
renovables de una manera ya por fin
práctica en esta unión europea que no
nos haga depender de fuentes energéticas
externas porque sean de origen carbónico
pero sobre todo no depender de fuera
sino de nosotros mismos y hay
posibilidades y tenemos las tecnologías
en europa para hacerlo
manu la unión europea europea debería de
ser debería de apostar por otro tipo de
energía debería de apostar por energías
renovables pero no ya por romper su
dependencia con rusia sino porque es
necesario para cuidar el planeta
puede mantener la unión europea está
esta ruptura con rusia pues puede ser
puede ser porque como desgraciadamente
ya esté planteado antes no decidimos
nuestra política sino que nuestra
política se decide en eeuu y resulta que
he estado unido el gran beneficiado de
esta crisis porque nos va a vender el
gas a un 233 por ciento más caro del que
se lo compramos rusia está la empresa
armamentística están contentísima con
esta situación porque porque están
haciendo el negocio del siglo pues me
temo que sí vamos seguir andando en ese
camino porque jugamos desgraciadamente
en vez de jugar un papel decidido por
nosotros jugamos el papel de mayordomo
del todo un link que
nos puede estar de acuerdo acaba de
aprobarse la brújula estratégica la
autonomía estratégica en materia de
defensa de la unión europea es decir
respecto a nuestros estados miembros la
unión europea como tal en materia de
defensa lógicamente no existe y es lo
que estamos construyendo ahora y
queremos que sea independiente siempre
relacionada con la otan pero claro con
criterios europeos tal vez haya sido lo
que se dice un wake up con una llamada
de atención a que los europeos
despertemos también en esa materia y no
dependemos de otros ni de estados unidos
ni de nadie más en cuestiones de
tecnología en cuestiones de inversión en
cuestiones para la defensa de nuestros
propios ciudadanos de nuestras fronteras
evidentemente dependemos de nuestro
mismo no de los demás en eso sí yo
podría estar de acuerdo pero
desgraciadamente si uno es un vecino que
está molestando todo el día a los demás
tiene que estar armándose hasta los
dientes tienes que llenar la casa de
puertas acorazadas de ventanas blindadas
pues porque los vecinos quizás no están
contentos con tu papel si nosotros
jugamos otro papel que en vez de ser
el preferido del matón de la clase y
vamos ahora nos enfadamos con russian
nosotros vamos a pelearnos con rusia
eeuu está lejos estado unido todas las
guerras que montan monta muy lejos de su
territorio ahora nosotros tenemos que
pelearnos con rusia y rusia no le tenga
estado unido no pega a nosotros y mañana
nos peleamos consignas y pasado mañana
nos peleamos con bielorrusia pues normal
que tengamos que apostar por incrementar
ejércitos nosotros desde luego no
apostamos por eso nosotros apostamos por
tener una convivencia en paz horizontal
en el que en el que podamos jugar un
papel no de
soldaditos de arietes de peones de eeuu
y no jugar un papel propio que apueste
por la paz por la independencia por el
respeto a la independencia de la
soberanía pero como podemos hacer eso
con vladimir putin o sea te quiero decir
yo siempre me has visto que yo no hablo
de rusia no hablo de los rusos hay una
oposición democrática en rusia a
diferencia de china donde dirige el
partido comunista de china es decir cómo
hacemos para que vladimir putin entienda
eso como lo estamos haciendo con
marruecos donde no era una democracia
ejemplar como lo estamos haciendo con
arabia saudita donde no es una
democracia ejemplar o como lo estamos
haciendo con israel donde no son en
democracia pero ahí no ha habido la
acción de más
de 40 acción por parte de estado
marroquí ha estado comiendo es como si
ha sido de parte de putin lo siento nos
hemos quedado sin tiempo pero muchísimas
gracias por este debate tan vivo y tan
interesante a los dos a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy gracias por ver france24 en
español
[Música]